hi Chris how are you I'm very well Cory
it's absolutely lovely to see you it's
great to see you too you somehow you're
always smiling no matter how dangerous
weird crazy things are thank you for
that you know you don't see me in the
other room crying afterwards but we'll -
Chris this is week three of these
conversations how are you thinking about
the people we should be speaking with I
mean there are so many aspects to this
right there's understanding the basic
pandemic itself and all day at the
science around that there's the
psychology that we're all going through
the mindset and we've had speakers
addressing both of these and then I
think increasingly the conversation is
going to be what now how do we how do we
dig ourselves out of this what's what's
the way forward and there's a couple
speakers this week focused on that and I
think it's these conversations are
incredibly rich because well I think one
of the things that people have got
growing consensus on is that step one we
kind of get right you you shut things
down physically distance in whatever way
you can different countries are going
about it slightly differently but but
basically that quote flattens the curve
ultimately the number of cases and
reflexes slow slows down and then what
because you can't go back to life as
normal when you're living at home
completely you could do some things but
but but you can't and so that that's
that's what we're going to talk about
today right it feels really really
hopeful to talk about some actions we
can take besides just staying away from
everybody else so um well I guess I'll
pass it over to you to introduce the
speaker and I will come back a little
bit later to share some questions from
our audience
thanks so much Corey's see you again in
a bit thank you and yes if you if you
know anyone out there who has has just
got stuck on but how do people get back
to work
what do we go where do we go from here
those are the people who you should
maybe invite them into this conversation
right now because I think they're going
to be really interested our speaker our
guest is a professor at Harvard Daniel
Allen do runs among other things do runs
an Institute for Ethics they're the
Safra Institute and and so fundamentals
you think about the ethical questions
about what's happening here but she has
pulled together an extraordinary
multidisciplinary team of economists
business leaders and others who have put
together a plan and I've been obsessed
with this whole thing and how how we
find our way out this this plan is as
compelling a plan as I've seen anywhere
so let's dig into it without further ado
Daniel Allen welcome here to Ted
connects thank you Chris happy to be
here I'm really really grateful to have
a chance to have this conversation
yeah it's it's it's so good I've just
enjoyed our conversation over the last
couple of days that this is this is such
a complex problem let's that's what I
kind of want to do is just go through it
step by step you see the logic of what
it is that your your team are putting
forward I mean first of all the just the
the problem itself of how we get the
economy going again just talk about a
bit about what's at stake there because
sometimes this is framed as the economy
who cares about the economy people's
lives are at stake you know so let's
just focus on that don't worry about the
economy but it's not as simple as that I
mean as an emphasis what's at stake if
we don't restart the economy somehow but
we have to recognize that we've actually
faced two existential threats
simultaneously the first was to the
public health system if the virus had
been allowed to unfold unimpeded our
public health systems would have
collapsed and that would have produced a
whole legitimacy crisis for our public
institutions so of course we shut down
we had to do that it was a necessary
self-defense action that has however
really devastated the economy and that
is also an existential threat we can
actually endure a closed economy over a
duration of 12 to 18 months nor can we
really endure a situation where we don't
know whether we might have another two
to three months of extensive social
distancing so we really need an
integrated strategy one that recognizes
both of these existential threats and
finds a way to control the disease at
the same time that we can keep the
economy open we call that combination of
controlling the disease while keeping
the economy open pandemic resilience we
think that's what we should be aiming
for the people who aren't moved by the
notion of the economy capitalism
whatever think instead about the
millions of millions of jobs that were
lost the people who are desperate to
make money and I guess that the lives
that will be lost unless we solve this
problem absolutely I mean the economy is
one of the foundational pillars for a
healthy society with opportunity and
with justice you can't have a justice ID
either if you haven't secured a just and
and functioning economy that delivers
about being for people so and all we
have to do is remember back to 2008 and
think about the impact something suicide
and depression and so forth that flowed
from that recession so the economy is a
public health concern in the same way
that the virus is a public health
concern okay so talk about why this is
such an intractable problem people
isolate in many countries of the world
now you're starting to see the cases
flattened and in many cases decrease it
looks like at whether it's happened now
in your country or not that that will
happen sooner or later so why isn't that
problem solve we've we've beaten the
virus let's get back to work that's a
great question and it really speaks to
how new the experience for us is to
encounter a novel virus it just really
it hasn't happened to our society in a
very very long time so we are what's
called a susceptible population meaning
not any of us at the beginning of this
had immunity we were all susceptible to
catching the disease for society to be
safe it needs to have what's called herd
immunity you can achieve that through
vaccination or through people getting
the disease but it takes fifty to sixty
seven percent of the population to get
the disease in order to achieve that
level of protection we don't expect a
vaccine anytime
next twelve months possibly 18 months so
we have to recognize if that pathway
it's not open to us and to get a sense
of the magnitude of what it would mean
to live through the disease to get to
hurt immunity
think about this in Italy right now they
estimate that about 15% of the
population has probably been exposed to
the disease so you'd have to go you know
repeat what Italy's done three or you
know more times to get to a place where
you could reasonably think that there's
hurt immunity and I think you can see
that when you think of that picture how
do you stabilizing a process would be of
just making things broadly open without
disease controls so the real trick is
whether or not there's a substitute for
social distancing as a method for
controlling the disease right so Italy
even with that 15% has suffered at least
15,000 deaths some people argue that
it's underreported by 50 percent there
might be 30,000 deaths plus there and as
they come down the curve there'll be
more to come multiply that by five or
six a for the bigger population size of
the US and you it the herd immunity idea
per se doesn't seem like a winning idea
I mean I remember it's a that's the
important thing we actually do have a
way of controlling the disease
minimizing loss of life and reopening
the economy so that's the thing we
should all be focusing on and again the
initial problem is if you just let
people start coming back as soon as they
gather again in reasonable numbers the
risk is that this highly infectious bug
just takes off off again and and so one
scenario is that you have countries
lurching from a little bit of activity
here and then and then suddenly it
explodes again and everyone has to
retreat but that does not seem
attractive that's that also just doesn't
work no exactly I mean we describe that
as a freeze in place strategy for
dealing this with this that as you
freeze and you shut down all activity
and then that flattens the curve you
open up again then you have another peak
you have to freeze again and so forth so
you have this repeated process of
freezing which just does tremendous
damage to the economy over time and the
upfront damage is huge but then there's
never space to recover from it because
of great deal of uncertainty
repeated applications of economically
ruinous social distancing so I think you
know you're really pointing to the
features of the disease that make this
situation the problem that it is and
they're really two that people should
focus on one is the degree of
infectiousness this is a highly
infectious virus so the comparison to
the Spanish flu is a reasonable one from
the point of view of degree of
infectious infectiousness then the
second really important point about the
disease is that it's possible to be an
asymptomatic carrier that is to be
infectious to carry the virus and never
show any symptoms yourself current
estimates are still emphasized but
people think that about 20% of virus
carriers are asymptomatic and that is
really the thing that makes it so hard
to control people don't know they're
sick and then they become disease
vectors spreading it everywhere they go
yes indeed so talk a bit Danyelle about
your thinking about how we might outwit
this thing so the alternative to social
distancing as a strategy for controlling
the disease is really massively ramped
up massively scale about testing
combined with individual quarantine so
we are going to continue to need
individual quarantine for those who are
positive carriers of the virus until
such a point as we have gotten a vaccine
now what does that mean exactly
it means that the the standard
quarantine that aligns with the
incubation period 14 days is often what
people talk about in a conservative
picture you might say twice the
incubation period length 28 days for an
individual quarantine and we need that
quarantine for people who are
symptomatic and for asymptomatic
carriers of the virus now the only way
that you can actually run an individual
quarantine as opposed to a collective
quarantine regime is if you do massive
testing we really need to make testing
in a sense universally available so that
we can be testing broadly across the
population there are ways to target
testing make it more efficient and so
forth but in principle what one should
imagine is really a wide scale testing
tens of millions of tests a day
connected with in quarantine for those
who test positive excuse me so weird
anyone anytime anyone coughs okay
[Laughter]
so just to plow a thought experiment if
if we had an infinite number of tests
available and after after the curve is
flattened in cases have gone down
everyone came back to work but everyone
was tested every day then what we think
is that the tests will show up positive
but at the same time or possibly even
ahead of the time that people are
infectious but sunny let's say at the
same time even regardless of whether
they're symptomatic and so you could
those people would immediately go go
back home and the rest of the population
should be okay we should be able to get
work done in that 40 experiment right
right in that thought experiment exactly
yeah but the trouble is that that that
would mean doing whatever 200 million
like tests a day which is many many
orders of magnitude more than we have
and could even imagine wrapping up to so
you have a proposal this is the
ingenuity the proposal of how to
potentially administer tests in a way
that's much more efficient talked a bit
about that sure
so if you were going to use a purely
random testing method to control the
disease you could probably actually get
away with testing everybody every two or
three days I'm just playing along with
your thought experiment here and bring
the number down to a hundred million
tests a day but even that is a magnitude
that would take us multiple months to
get to let's just say if we even wanted
to try to do something like that so the
thing that you really need is smart
testing so rather than testing the
population at random what you use do is
you use testing to identify people who
are positive and then you add to that
contact tracing or contact warning you
can we think about it in both ways and
what this means is that once you know
who's a positive test you figure out who
else has been exposed to that person
over the previous two weeks and they all
get tested as well so you start to
identify a class of people who are
higher probability of being infectious
and you test that group of people so you
you move away from random testing you
target it through a contact tracing or
contact warning
and then depending on the level of
effectiveness of your contact tracing
and contact warning testing or strategy
you can reduce the numbers so on a
moderately effective contact tracing
regimen you could imagine doing 20
million tests a day on a highly
effective regime of contact tracing and
testing rewarding to get yourself down
to the order of five to ten million
tests today and the some countries in
Asia seem to have bought off a version
of this strategy that has been effective
but it requires one of two things if I
understand you right then yeah it
requires either just this massively
scaled up or potentially quite intrusive
sort of manual contact tracing where you
have big teams who swooped in to anyone
who's tested positive and try to unpack
their complete recent social history or
technology plays a role and this is
where it gets complicated because you
know that there are apps in some of the
Asian countries like China has an app
which most people are I think required
to carry it certainly in Wuhan and
elsewhere where where it it's very good
at predicting whether someone may need
quarantine on it and and they will be
required to do so and so there are all
these concerns about government control
government intrusion youth you are in
discussion about ways of doing some kind
of technology that would be more
acceptable in a democracy and I'd love
you to share what those are sure no
happy to do that so I think it's an
important thing to say at front that the
rates at which we would need to test per
capita are higher much higher than Asian
countries used because prevalence is
much higher here they caught it earlier
they had these tools built before the
pandemic hit as a consequence they're
able to control it with a lower per
capita rate of testing than will be the
case for us we just have to accept that
fact at this point and recognize that
massively scaling up is specific to our
situation because we weren't ready
before it hit so then yes okay if we're
trying to do the smart testing trying to
use tools what can you do
so we're actually open to manual testing
and the plan that we've developed I want
to just say that I think the society we
have a big choice
to make whether what we want is a big
core of manual contact tracers who are
facing people's histories and figuring
out who they've been in contact with and
who they've been exposed to or if we
want to try to use a technological
system the important thing is our
diversity of options within the
technology space so it's really
important to recognize that places like
Singapore and China have used highly
centralized data systems for supporting
this and so what happens is you sort of
you carry your phone around and
everybody is connected to a central data
system and then when somebody in the
system has a positive test that gets put
into the app and then their phone
communicates to other phones that it's
been in proximity with over the previous
two weeks to alert people that they to
need to get a test okay that's the basic
concept in China and Singapore the data
structure for doing this is highly
centralized there are however a lot of
innovative apps under development right
now that depend instead on a very
privacy protective structure where the
data lives on the individual users phone
and through a combination of encryption
and tokens users of phones could
communicate with other users of phones
but the data is not centralized so in
that regard it becomes more of a
peer-to-peer sharing of a sort of
concept of friends warned friends that
they should probably go get tested then
you would have a central repository of
test data or the truth is we already
have that because all influenza tests
for example already roll up into CDC and
human health and services databases so
that they can track influenza patterns
every year so tell me if I understand
this right then that you would carry on
your phone an app that would when you
got say within six feet of another human
carrying that app the phone's would
exchange a Bluetooth using Bluetooth
technology like they exchange our kind
of token that says hi we connected but
it's encrypted
and that is not communicated to a
central server that is on the phone that
if you either review in the next week or
two past positive your phone will be
able to communicate to all the people
which it's exchange token whiz to say oh
someone who
were close to the last two weeks has
tested positive you've got to isolate
that that's basically how it works but
it's it's done that way and the exact
data and then after after what three or
four weeks that the tokens can actually
auto-delete because you only need the
most recent two weeks information or
data about where you've been and what
other phones your phone has interacted
with so that's really key all right
we'll come back we'll come back to that
in a minute but let's let's see what
what our friends are asking online okay
hi hi Daniel hi hi Chris yeah we've got
a lot of great questions people are
super interested in how this is all
going to work there's a couple of
questions I'm trying to kind of cobble
together here I think people are really
interested in your thoughts on the
United States healthcare system we have
so many underinsured and uninsured
people and the changes that you might
make to that system I mean does that
situation make things worse and what
changes would you make to the system so
that we're not as vulnerable in the
future so that's a great set of
questions and so just from the point of
view of the testing program it is
absolutely critical that the testing be
free and so there is absolutely a sort
of necessary feature of this which is
about universal access element to the
health system and so I'm sure there will
be tweaking that's necessary in the
existing health system to achieve that
we've also without any questions seen
vulnerabilities that relate to and stem
from our fragmented health system I
think there's a much bigger a
longer-term question to be had about our
conversation to have about how we
overcome that fragmentation so yes I do
hope this moment will be a spur for that
longer-term conversation about improving
our health system and really achieving
that universal coverage that we so badly
need okay thank you I'll see you both
again in a little bit thanks Cory let's
see I said let's stay with this tech
issue for a bit and the sort of civil
rights or privacy questions that it
might still
raised in some people so one one concern
is that totally if your phone is able to
contact these other phones someone
somewhere is ultimately going to reverse
that and will have some kind of record
of your but you know who everyone who
you've connected with and that might be
concerning to to some is that a
legitimate concern I think it is I mean
I think we've been working hard on this
question and really trying to think it
through and when you talk to legal
experts and civil liberties experts and
so forth everybody starts with the same
premise assume failure assume that
you'll have a data breach think for that
and what kind of protection you want in
that regard
and so when you think that way you of
course are trying to minimize any
likelihood of that happening so has the
privacy protective structure of phones
communicating with those data living on
the hard software the hardware the phone
I'm not in server cetera and then also
you would want to kind of democratic
accountability feature so for example
having the Department of Health and
Human Services have an auditing function
to audit the whoever is Manning the
server or you know controls the server
through which the tokens are exchanged
we'd want audit their functionality and
how they're using the data but then
again any sort of presume failure that
somebody's reverse engineering the audit
system fails in some fashion
what's your protection then and the
answer of that would appear to be
upfront legislation that the prohibits
the commercialization of this kovat
testing data so that anybody who in any
way tried to commercialize it in any
kind of way would be subject to legal
penalties so I think that's how you sort
of build the fence up up front to the
expectation that's somebody would find a
way to crack it and then there's a set
of questions around how you get this app
out there at scale because it's only
effective if they two-thirds of the
people who are working there carrying it
right something like that and and so
sort of you know Authority and everyone
must have this app I guess that there
are ways that are interesting to say to
people one this is a really useful app
it will alert you quickly if you are in
any risk but to to get to the kind of
scale we're talking about you might have
to say to people a lot
we're slowly going to come back to work
industry by industry company by company
in the deal for you to come back and
break isolation the societal deal is
that you have to be willing to to carry
this up and you could for people who
didn't want to do that I guess you could
have some protection you can't lose your
job for that but but I mean can you
pictures society making the choice that
it is reasonable to require people who
want to come back to work
to carry that alert technology with them
this is the hardest question we know we
don't want an authoritarian model such
as the one used in China and Singapore
so we have to figure out instead how to
activate that thing which is where the
most important democratic resource or
asset namely solidarity so what is it
that from a solidarity perspective it's
reasonable for us to ask of each other
that has to be the frame for deciding
how we approach this and so one aspect
of this is really truly the sort of
building a culture of opting in to this
and there are examples of this so for
example New York has tackled HIV testing
through a program goes by the label New
York knows it started out with the
labels like no Manhattan knows or
Brooklyn knows and so forth the
different boroughs and what this program
is is one that is owned by community
organizations community partners that do
the job of spreading the word and
recruiting people into testing programs
and New York has the goal of having
every single New Yorker be tested by for
HIV so in other words it's established
as a as an expectation that universal
participation and it's activated a
network of community partners and
organizations to cultivate that
commitment to solidarity and so I think
in all honesty that that would be a
really huge part of what you would need
to do in order to tap into solidarity to
have this work I'm sure that we would
see some amount of requiring in
different context I think that's a very
hard one because you don't want to
generate labor discrimination problems
and so the model there to think about it
or figure out where our parameter is
what we think is fair connects to things
that schools currently do for example
when they require that students show
vaccination proof before they can start
the school year
and things like that so there are
multiple states that do that in schools
for vaccines what schools do the same
thing what's the sort of labor the
workforce question like I think that is
very much remains to be worked through
but it's a hugely important question I'd
be curious what they watch the audience
thinks about this maybe you could enter
a comment on it but I mean is it
reasonable in the the world that we're
in right now for a company let's say to
say look we we want to get back to work
but we want to do so and respect the
safety of all our workers that means
that for you to come back to work you
need a test showing that your your
negative and you and you need to carry
this this app so that we can alert
people quickly if there's a problem is
that we won't fire you if you don't come
in but but if you want to come back to
work that's that's what you'll have to
agree to is that a reasonable dance I'm
curious what people think there is
precedent for this in the sense that
drug testing works this way in many
employment contexts
right there are many roles where people
have to do routine drug tests is a part
of preserving their their job that was a
hotly debated issue in the 1980s people
sort of think back when that sort of
first came in and there was a lot of
concern about it we have managed to
develop a regime for that that has
achieved an equilibrium of a kind so I
imagine that something is possible in
this space but we would have to draw on
the prior experience with things like
drug testing in the workplace I think I
mean one one problem that we face when
you when you think about these big
systems introduced is that in the past
there's there's history where something
got introduced you know you think of the
Patriot Act that came in after 9/11 and
a lot of people have a lot of problems
with that act and it gets renewed
relentlessly well to see here we are
nearly twenty years later and and it's
still with us that so that that creates
quite a high bar for any any standard
that we push out here is that how do we
how do we persuade people that this is
custom-made for the current situation
that we're in and it's not going to be
picked up and subsequently abused by
come
by government that's an absolutely
critical question and I think we have a
lot to learn from places like Germany
which are really really strong and
rigorous on privacy protections perhaps
having some of the highest privacy
protection standards in the world and
Germany over the course the last few
week has articulated an approach that
definitely picks up several of these
elements so there are ways of building
and privacy structures that are meeting
the standards of the German privacy
framework and so I think for us that's a
really important place to look to and
learn from them how they're structuring
it to achieve those privacy protections
you know you're an ethicist among other
things as well as a political theorist
and is it as you think about how to
apply ethical questions to this is it
inherent in a situation like this that
they're going to be trade offs that
there is no quote perfect solution that
we we just you know these things are
fundamentally you've got two goods that
are fundamentally in conflict with each
other or if you like avoidance or two
evils that are going to clash and that
we're not going to get away sort of
untainted to some extent we just have to
try and make the least bad choice so
that's it's a it's a great question and
I think I tend to formulate things as
being about hard choices and judgments
rather than being about trade-offs
I think trade-offs often suggest that
you can precisely quantify this degree
of monetizable harm against that degree
of monetizable harm and I think that's
actually not as helpful to us in this
current moment be honest so in effect I
think the most important things that we
clarify our core values and so the way
we've tried to articulate that is to say
we have a fundamental value in securing
public health we have a fundamental
value in securing a functioning healthy
economy you have a fundamental of value
in securing civil liberties and justice
and constitutional democracy and so then
the question is given that set of
fundamental values what are the policy
options that actually do secure all of
those things so in that regard at the
end of the day you know there's a bunch
of libertarians in the group that we
work on it a lot of us come out of very
strongly sort of protecting Liberty
protecting point of view and so we're
not here to sacrifice those things we're
rather here to find a solution that'll
with the values that we bring into this
problem so that's how we think about the
decision they talk a bit more actually
about the group that you've pulled
together over this I know that there's a
ten speaker Paul Roma and economist at
Stanford who who's I think a key member
who is in the group Paul was a key
member I'm afraid we parted ways to some
extent because he's advocating random
testing so the sort of direction and
he's not a fan of the contact tracing
approach so he does have you know he's
sort of at one end of a kind of
libertarian spectrum on that and my view
however is that 100 million a day is far
more intrusive than smart testing
supported by privacy protective contact
tracing I also think it's really
important to throw into the mix the fact
that collective social distancing is a
huge infringement on our civil liberties
we keep forgetting that the alternative
is not contact tracing versus noting its
contact tracing versus social distancing
we can't go out we can't form
associations where we get to be together
in person churchgoers can't go to church
right now you know political parties are
having their conventions postponed that
if that's not official have civil
liberties I don't know what is so from
my point of view the civil liberties
conversation as well as that the
contrast between the kind of
infringement that is produced by social
distancing versus the kind of
infringement towards reshaping that
would be imposed by contact tracing
regime I did moving so fast in real time
just talk about some of the other people
who are in your in your group sure so
Glen Wilde is an economist at Microsoft
Oakland economist is a really key figure
and he's really an innovative mechanism
design thinker who's really good at kind
of figuring out how to craft incentive
structures and so forth that help people
make choices in socially productive ways
in ways are also freedom respecting and
so forth so he's really been helping us
think about the design of the policy
pathway Rajiv Sethi is another economist
Lucas toxic is a philosopher at Harvard
who has been brutalizing the civil
liberties and justice
I mean that is his line of work those
are the things he's most committed to
and that's what he's doing
we've reached out to a number of public
health groups for regular consultations
so they're not as directly part of our
group in the sense of advancing a policy
but in terms of informing our
epidemiology fideya logical
understanding we've relied a lot on
folks at the Chan of School of Public
Health at Harvard so lawyers as well
Glenn Cohen who directs the PG Flom
Center for law and bioethics has been a
critical member andyc respo also at
Harvard Law School
Rose Brooks Georgetown Law School I
could go on I'm missing key political
scientists actually there's a great
paper on solidarity by Melanie Cabot and
Evan Lieberman that people should check
out too well it's exciting that one of
the impacts of this and I've seen it is
in other areas as well that this this
crisis is really breaking a lot of cross
disciplinary lines and bring people
together in unexpected combinations
which is good no yes how if this plan
got general acceptance how obviously the
clock is ticking this is urgent
what would it look like to move this
forward give a sense of what you think
it would cost give a sense of how who
might own it like what would it take to
actually activate this giant idea all
right so it's a big price tag so I hope
you're sitting down I'm glad you're
sitting down so over two years based on
conservative estimates of what you would
need that is a maximal estimates for
testing and things like that it's got a
price tag of 500 billion which includes
both the production of tests and the
personnel of test administration and
contact tracing and all of that so it's
important to remember though that that
production ramped up and the contact
tracing ramp up our employment
possibilities so in that regard they
would counteract the negative impact on
employment of the social distancing so
it's a big price tag but it would be
multi-purpose in that regard
dumping you're contributing to jumping
up the economy as well as the testing
program itself it would be important
that it be phased in and phasing it in
would actually give us a way of testing
out the paradigm as we went so for
example for a first phase of rollout
probably what you would want to do
ideally though by the end of the next
month would be to have a full range of
testing for a combination of everybody
in the healthcare sector and everybody
who might fill in and substitute for any
healthcare workers who test positive so
in other words your healthcare worker
pool and a substitute pool say a
National Service Corps are folks who can
fill in for health care workers who test
positive if you could get those two
groups those two sectors fully under a
sort of testing contact tracing regime
so that you know that every healthcare
worker is not positive and anybody who
is is immediately quarantined and so
forth we would stabilize our public
health infrastructure and that would
already get about thirty percent of the
workforce under this kind of testing and
tracing regime and then you'd move on
with that stabilized to other critical
and essential workers etc so the bad
news this is you know who would be the
last people to be folded into this bu it
would be me and be the people can
actually tell a commute for work okay
because we would have the least call on
social needs to pull us back out into
the workforce so we'd be the last ones
out but that's a good thing I think
that's a part of making the point that
we're all in this together and that
there's a stat there sacrifices of
different places and service workers
care workers and so forth we would be
able to get out faster and that
addresses what is definitely one of the
most shocking and painful aspects of the
current moment which is you know for
those of us in sort of working from home
it feels traumatic it's not nothing like
what others are experiencing whose life
is and some being out there doing
examining physical work and so I think
it's excellent obviously the plan
focuses on on them first how applicable
is this to other countries you obviously
talking the plan is developed for the
for the u.s. yes it's it's inspired by
what's happened in some ways what's
happened in some Asian countries is it
applicable to other countries as well it
absolutely is and we're already seeing
Europe moving this way so Europe and the
UK are ahead of us on this point I mean
the rough shape of the plan that we're
proposing so you pretty much the rough
shape of the plan that's emerging in
Europe and the UK so you know I think
it's a really important moment to bring
together those policy conversations
bring together those mom
conversations and help each other out on
this and I guess that the reason I'm
delighted that you're engaged in this is
that it's it's it you know it's
fundamentally framed here as this is a
discussion that society has to have
their ethical choices we have to as as
part of this and so we can't just leave
it up to it the scientists as brilliant
as they are and and the politicians are
gonna say like we all need to understand
what is at stake here what the choices
are what the hard choices are and I know
that any direction is tricky but we you
know that this this really this really
matters absolutely if you put it so well
I think that's what makes this kind of
question different in a democracy it
really is important that we all
collectively achieve understanding have
clarity about the directional options
and have a sense of collectively moving
in a direction that we desire right that
we that we consent you in a sense Corrie
hi I just wanted to come back and give
you a little feedback on what people are
saying online in terms of the testing to
be able to go up back to work you know
how people feel about that obviously
there's lots of questions about the app
and privacy some people are hesitant
about it they're wondering you know
whether it would be mandatory which you
touched on you know maybe you opt in to
be able to go back in the office I'm in
I would test to be able to go back in
the office myself but I think people are
wondering about that but the general
consensus is it seems like a reasonable
possibility there are a couple of
questions to one I think you just
touched on in terms of the global
possibilities do you see some
collaboration the global landscape do
you see people talking to each other
obviously if we want international
travel to come back that seems like a
key piece of it yes so I think travel is
one of the hardest pieces of this and
actually I don't think that there are
good clear answers on that yet
scientists are talking to each other
across national international boundaries
without any questions I think the
scientific community is really well
networked real connected trying to think
about these things
it's not clear to me how well networks
the policymaking community is no honesty
I think that there's probably a lot of
room for building a tighter
international network of policy makers
on that front and the hardest part is
going to be the travel piece and
honestly you know we haven't even talked
about parts of the globe like Africa or
India on South America where they're not
yet you know sort of getting towards
this post paradigm so the virus is going
to live in the world without any
question and live in the world probably
in quite significant ways for a
considerable period of time so I think
the role of travel restrictions is
probably going to be with us for a spell
and so it really does matter that we get
the design of those right
I think it's Hong Kong that has it
particularly what looks to me like a
sort of useful regime where anybody who
is coming into Hong Kong for longer than
two weeks has to go into a 14 day
quarantine when they arrive but for
anybody who's coming for a shorter time
they have to be tested when they arrive
and then they have to also go through
active monitoring during the period of
their time in Hong Kong which means
having temperature checks and so forth
reported so I think that's a reasonable
thing to do in order to keep business
travel up and running even as we're all
trying to deal with controlling the
virus and you also mentioned solidarity
and I think that touches on another
question that someone brought up online
about some of the social impacts after
the 1918 epidemic and the fear and the
you know the fear of the other and
foreigners and all then how do we get
through this without kind of fall out
and you know how do we kind of keep
ourselves together and looking out for
each other I think that's such a hugely
important question and I mean in one
sense it's easy because you know the
virus is an adversary to every human
being equally right we're all completely
equal in relationship to it and so what
we're really all aspiring to here is
sort of transformation of our basic
socio-economic infrastructure in a way
that
but sits on a footing to be pandemic
resilient so I have something I've been
using the metaphor of we need to put
ourselves on the war footing to mobilize
the economy to fight the virus and I
stand by that in the sense that we do
need to mobilize the economy and so
forth but really at the end of the day
it's not a war against a human adversary
or anything of that kind and so what
we're really talking about goes back to
the questions about the health
infrastructure and healthcare we're
really talking about achieving a
transformed peace situation where our
economies in our societies are pandemic
resilient that's the real goal here and
it really does require an investment so
because of the 2003 SARS experience
Asian nations have been investing over
the last five years we're plus a min
pandemic resilient equipment and
infrastructure we haven't done that in
the US so we find ourselves in a
position where we have to accelerate in
a matter of months something that has
taken other people years to build and
develop so I think really focusing on
that and the goal is an economy that's
not vulnerable to pandemic right I mean
because we don't want to leave this
pandemic and have the economy be just as
vulnerable to pandemic at the end of the
pandemic as we were at the beginning of
the pandemic we don't want to be
vulnerable this way and so in that
regard
you know the job is to build in that
infrastructure for pandemic resilience
ASAP Wow Tony opium you know given the
price tag you're talking about on this
half a half a trillion dollars basically
up to yeah
that's literally less than some of the
multi trillion dollar numbers that are
getting thrown around so I mean in the
in terms of the scale of the problem
it's it's probably an appropriate number
but it sounds like it's a have any
chance to doing this does it have to be
a kind of a federal initiative at some
level yeah so yeah we have a problem
that more than half the country
fundamentally doesn't trust key parts of
the of the administration let's say how
could this be framed in a way that could
build trust and make it make it feel
like this is the country as a whole that
there's this coalition of trusted voices
who are the final decision-makers on
so you know we have this incredible
federalist system and we need to see it
as an asset its mod realized and
flexible and we need to activate that we
do need all the parts of the system
working so we do need the federal
government working on behalf of this we
need the state governments working and
municipal governments on the federal end
of things we need Congress to fund so in
the first instance there's a really big
need for funding legislation and also
Congress can really help by directing
investments not just in the testing
program itself but in the kind of
National Service Corps probably flowing
through state governments through the
National through the servers that
reserves in every state that would be
sort of health reserves he has really
expand that program the accommodation of
an Employment Program and backing up
that sector so there's a lot for
Congress to do as a part of this for the
testing program we really do need the
kind of procurement in order to produce
capacity that the Defense Department is
the best example of so in the ideal a
sort of testing supply board that
brought in leading figures who are
masters in supply chain logistics from
the private sector working in close
coordination with the federal government
would be great
the White House has recently in the last
week or so begun to put in pieces of
architecture that goes in this way sort
of a testing supply czar for example of
an admiral and Admiral I believe so we
need people of that kind who are really
superb masters of logistics procurement
contracts and that sort of thing to be
able to ramp up the an active functional
supply chain for testing to deliver at
the border of tens of millions of tests
a day so we do need absolutely as a key
part of that key driver of that and so
it's a time for all the parts of our
government to come together and do their
respective pieces so I'm kind of in
order to scale it what you're thinking I
guess as we wrap up here I'd either if I
might I'd love to just go to a bit more
personal place I can just about you and
and what what is it in your past that is
sort of is providing the fire right now
the drive to try to
do this how are you how are you feeling
about this that what you know tell us a
bit about you please very generous
question you know it's like I love this
country I'll admit that's where the
motivation starts from in a sense that
lost people was am a global humanitarian
and watching the world to come to the
disease motivates me like I think of
Paul Farmer for example as an example of
that I respect that and I get that but I
at the end of a like I love my country
and it hurt just hurt in the beginning
of this and it hurt particularly was I
was very clear early on that I was
getting better information as a member
of the Harvard faculty than my fellow
parishioners than the people who were
serving me in restaurants and cafes and
it just like that made me angry
in all honesty as it was a combination
of those two things I was like hey I
want to understand this and be I want to
share what I understand because it's not
fair that people like me get it and
that's not being shared with other
people hmm well that's powerful I think
all of us Whitney I like that we all
feel this if we had mixture of almost
guilt at how fortunate to position some
of us in certainly a lot of gratitude
anger Oh will you persuaded Whitney by
by this by this idea by the possibility
of a quarry that's absolutely be
mistaken for Whitney it's a huge
compliment
it's very persuasive and I think so
hopeful to hear a constructive plan and
a feeling that you know there is a path
out of this that is both possible for us
as humans to get back to being together
but then also as an economy and as a
country I'm really inspired by your work
and so grateful to you for sharing
with us I appreciate that thank you I'm
really glad to get a chance to talk
about it and share the knowledge that we
our group has acquired over the last
month so thank you so if someone wants
to keep in touch with the progress of
this idea what should they do okay so
now I should know our website URL by
heart but of course I don't I'm afraid
so if kovat COV ID Safra safr a allen al
lem that's my surname our website will
come up so if you just rubber those
three words kovat Safra allen and google
that you should get to our white papers
op-eds things like that we are hoping to
have our full policy roadmap published
by the end of the week that's our target
goal so yeah it's a harvard dot edu okay
exactly
excu to the atlantic gauge and then to
the current site letter covered 19 from
there yeah exactly yeah all right well
thank you so much Daniel I found this
absolutely fascinating you like gonna
take it's going to take I mean this is
not an ordinary idea we don't often
attach have someone come and say yeah
I've got this idea for how to spend half
a trillion dollars between us and other
places around the world actually getting
the economy going again but that's not
usual so and give to us today thank you
for that and thank you to everyone
listening this is an important debate
and it's not finished yet that there
will be many other contributions to
ideas like this I think and so yeah
tripping ship in ship in thank you all
so much for being part of this today
we're back again tomorrow
Corey do you have you have details on
that I do and also you can listen to
this conversation on our website said
calm or on Facebook and you can also
listen to the recording of it through
Ted interview so if you missed any parts
of it or you want to pass it along
to a friend we have some more amazing
speakers coming up I might glance at my
cheat sheet but tomorrow we have esther
chu who is a emergency physician and
professor and she's gonna share with us
what she's seen on the frontlines of
this crisis on wednesday Chris and I'll
be speaking with Ray Dalio the founder
of Bridgewater and he's gonna address
the market and economic implications of
this pandemic and on Thursday we have
two speakers Gayatri the Vasu boudin
who's going to share with us what's
happening in India and Fareed Zakaria a
journalist Friday will wrap things up
with musician and artist Jacob Coulier
so we have a lot of amazing things
coming up we do so come do it if you can
apart for anything else we just like
your company here every day so hope
we'll get through this together thanks
thanks so much for being part of this
Daniel thanks again thank you bye